こんにちは
はじめにいい
一つみなさんに
お聞きたいんですけれども
この中の皆さんデー
自分の人生の将来でもうやりたいことが
決まっているっていう人というのはどれ位
いらっしゃいますかちょっと手を上げて
いただけますか
本文いないかぐらいかですかね
わかりましたはいありがとうございます
僕はですねー
今でこそ
国境なき医師団の事務局長としてこういう
ヘッドトークに呼ばれていますけれども
大学時代は全然誇れる学生じゃなかった
です
一浪して入ったんですけれども
ああの子かわいいなとか
あの子もなかなかとかそんなことばっかり
考えてましたん
勉強はテスト期間の時だけしてあとは
サークル三昧と
そんなことですから当時は就職氷河期と
いうこともあって
大学3年生の時の
僕の就職活動全滅しました
どこにエントリーシートを出しても1社
からも一次面接にすら呼ばれなかったん
です
バイっ
どうしようと本当に当方にくれました
当時僕は偏差値のコンプレックスがあった
んですね
どうせ
自分の人生というのは大きなことなんてが
できないと勝手に決めてましたん
就職留年をしてもう割り切っ
過去はもうしょうがない
でももしこれから何か一つの大きな夢に
向かって毎日一生懸命頑張れば10年後
20年後どうなるんだろう
やってみたいというふうに思うようになり
ました
大学を卒業して北が入ったのは会社の it
企業営業職です
学歴の関係のない実力主義の世界でやって
みたいというのが一番大きかったです
ただ
ある程度仕事ができるようになってきた
とき
この仕事を自分の人生でずっとやっていて
いいのかなぁと悩みました
いや違う
僕は
世界の現実というのを自分の目で見て
みたいな
テレビとか新聞とかからだけではなくて
できれば見るだけではなくて
世界で最も弱い立場にいる人たちのために
仕事を通じて貢献したいというのがあり
ました
それで難民というのをキーワードにして
ネットで検索してました
なるほど
緒方貞子さんの unhcr があるな
そういえば
赤十字があるん
国境なき医師団
なんか聞いたことあるなどういう組織
だろう
国境なき医師団は独立した国際的な医療人
道援助団体です
1999年にノーベル平和賞をもらってい
ます
いちばんの特徴は活動資金の9割以上を
民間からの寄付で賄っていることです
公立校か責任を追及する
プロフェッショナルな人道援助団体です
調べてみると
お医者さんとか看護師さんだけではなくて
ヒトモノカネが便で
援助活動に貢献する非医療の2ッフも実は
半分ぐらい入ると
ここであれば自分のしたいことが経験
できるし自分をより成長させることが
できるなというふうに思って
どうしても入りたいというふうに思うよう
になりました
でも
入団試験僕実は2回落ちてるんですね
英語が全く
当時できなかったんです
会社を辞めてましたので
アルバイトとしてあのフリーターですよね
いろんなアルバイトを前にしながら
英語の勉強してました
1年半が経った頃ようやく電話が鳴りまし
た
緒方さん
アフリカの
スーダンの
ダルフールという所に行ってみませんか
よしと
そこからですよ僕の国境なき医師団での
仕事が始まったのは
初めは
路地してちゃんと言う
物資の調達管理をする責任者でした
ダルフールはまるで違う惑星のようでした
紛争のために
着の身着のまま
も取るものも持てず命からがら逃れてきた
国内避難民という人たちが
当時およそ
180人万人180万人ぐらいいました
誰が悪いのか分からない
ただ
傷跡だけが残っていく
家はない学校もない
でも命はある
そういう苦境にいる人たちのために国境
なき医師団は6勝で医療人道援助を届けて
いました
一番印象に残ったのは
同僚たちの姿です
おとなしく自分の国で働いていればもっと
快適なはずの暮らしを自分の家族や友人
たちと過ごせるはずなのに
わざわざアフリカの紛争地にまで来て自分
の人生とまったく関係のない人たちに
毎日朝早くから一生懸命
仕事をしていると
ものすごいモチベーションがピュアな人
たちだなと思いました
でも仕事はプロなんですね
外科医
増井回手術看護師小児科医
医療のスタッフも高いレベルで援助活動に
仕事に貢献できる人たちばかりでした
自分の同僚を誇れる
思えたんですね
自分たちがやっている仕事の必要性も
インパクトも目に見えて分かりました
こういう組織でこういう人たちと一緒に
仕事をしていきたいと強く思うようになり
ました
それ以来のべ10年間僕はアフリカと中東
なので特に紛争地で
医療人道援助をしてきました
でも実は1度だけ
この仕事を
やめたいと思ったことがあります
それは現地の厳寺の活動責任者として
シリアにいるときのことです
2011年から続いているシリアの内戦は
今世紀最悪の人道危機というふうに言われ
ています
そこでは戦闘員とオボ力を持っていない
一般市民とが全く区別されず
住宅地や学校や病院が
無差別に攻撃されていました
膨大な医療のニーズに比べて自分たちが
やっていることは
大海の一滴にすぎないんじゃないかと
プレスリリースで国際人道法遵守すべきと
いうふうに訴えても全く状況が良くなら
ない
悪化する一方の内戦の日がに対し
無力感が募っていった
この仕事を辞めようと思ってました
でもある患者さんとの会話がその後の僕の
人生に大きな影響を与えました
自分と同年代の彼は
空爆で家族を亡くして自分の右足もなくし
てました
手術を終えてベッドに横たわっているから
に
僕は国境なき医師団の活動責任者としては
あるまじきなんですけれども
人道支援の限界
この仕事の愚痴ですねそれをちょっとこう
彼に言ってしまったんです
その時
僕よりももっと絶望の淵にいるはずの彼ら
こういったんです
freedom
結愛は方
そう
プレートんせいだ
僕は言葉に詰まりました
you are a
そうだったのかと
自分と自分のチームはそんな風に現地の人
達から思われていたのか
それまで僕は活動の責任者としてこれ
ぐらい予算を使っているんだったらこれ
ぐらいの患者数がいないといけないという
数字を記念していたところがありました
どこかれ
気づかされたんです
戦争による暴力の被害者の人たちからすれ
ば現場で
現地のフタ付たちと一緒になって前線で
働いている僕らの姿っていうのは
世界のすべてからまだ完全に見捨てられて
いないという希望にもなり得るんだと
一昨年
僕は国境なき医師団日本の事務局長になり
ました
日本の社会で
人道支援に対する支持を広げて
日本から現場により大きなサポートを
届ける
これが国境なき医師団の今のあなたに掲げ
たミッションです
国境なき医師団の挑戦は続きます
でも
一つ
大きな問題があります
それが医療への攻撃です
僕が2年間赴任していたシリアのアレッポ
というところではテロとの戦いという名目
で反政府側にある医療施設が次々と空爆に
あって破壊されてきました
医療医の攻撃で一番の問題は
その医療施設で働いている
医療スタッフや患者さんたちが被害にあう
ということに加えて
その病院を命綱にしている
現地の何万人という人たちから医療への
アクセスが奪われて結果として助かるはず
の命が助からなくなっていくことです
それが自分と自分のチームの目の前で何回
も行われていました
数え切れないほどの机るはずの命が作れ
なかったんです
僕は今をそうなんですが
目を閉じると
いろんな
亡くなった人の顔が浮かんでくるんです
現地スタッフのお顔
一緒に働いた
現地のとみゅにてぃの人たちの顔
そして現地の病院長たちの顔
非常に憤りを覚えました
それがシリアだけでなくてアフガニスタン
やイエメンなどでも起きていました
その経験から
今日の人道危機で最も大事な問題の一つは
医療医の攻撃を削減することであるという
ふうに僕は思うようになりました
でもどうすればいいのか
国境なき医師団のような人道援助組織が
国際政治の現実の下でどうしたら
医療への攻撃を少なくすることができるん
だろう
僕はその問題に客観的に広い視野から
取り組むために
一旦国境なき医師団から離れて大学院で
勉強することにしました
大学院入試で一番大事なのはエッセイです
ハーバードケネディスクールでは
はリジーはキャリア号
っていうテーマのエッセイがありました
僕はこう書きました
私のキャリアゴールは
紛争地で援助を必要としている人たちの
医療へのアクセスを増加させて助かるはず
の位置が助かる環境を作ることです
そのために喫緊の課題である
医療への攻撃を少なくさせるための
アドボカシー戦略をハーバードで描きたい
んだっ
合格しました
女王 sknd フェローシップという名
の大変名誉ある授業料の全額奨学金付きで
ハーバードケネディスクールでの留学生活
はめちゃくちゃ楽しかったです
勉強は死ぬほど大変でしたけれども
ただやらされている感っていうのはゼロ
でした
自分がやりたい勉強ばっかりだったから
です
夜中のこの問題を解決したいという問題
意識を持った
自分と同じ40歳前後のミッドキャリアの
人たちが世界中から集まってくるところ
でした
政治家や
軍人
完了
ジャーナリスト
国連職員の彼らと
一緒になってよりよい世界にする為にいつ
かしても繰り返せば毎日は僕の人生の
大きな財産になっています
さてここで皆さんに質問です
日本に生まれた皆さんは心からの五女って
いうのを持ってますか
僕は高校時代偏差値50でした
大学生のとき就活で全敗しました
でも国境なき医師団で日本人初の現地の
活動責任者になりました
今は日本人初の事務局長としてやってい
ます
同一人物です
そこがポイントです
以前
テレビねー
ある有名人の人がこんなことを言ってまし
た
才能と努力というのが一から号まであると
才能市の人が1しか努力しないと1かける
市で1日がならないと
でもご努力すれば後になるなりますねと
才能後の人が号努力すれば
25になるけれども
1しか努力しないところにしかならない
なるほどなぁと思ってその時は聞いてい
ました
でもこのロジックだと
僕のケースが説明つかないんですね
僕の考えはこうです
才能というのは人によって一から号ぐらい
までしか違いがなかったとしても
努力というのは後で終わるものではなくて
6ひち初と
ずっと無限大に続けることができる
もちろん大変なんですけれどもそれを下
支えするのが夢であり
理想
そして大きな志
これを描けるか描けないか
持っているか持っていないかでその人の
人生で努力できる量っていうのが変わって
くるんです
今の自分がいます
まず大事なのは個人としてどうなりたいか
です
でも出来ればそこで終わるんじゃなくて
どの分野でもいいので public に
対する使命感というのを持つことができ
たらその人はより強くなれると僕は思う
思います
もちろん今の自分と理想の自分とでは
差がありますので
そのギャップを埋めていくための
アクションを1歩ずつ取っていく
もう1歩1歩入っ
それの繰り返しです
まとめです
今日自分の経験から皆さんにお伝えしたい
ことは次の3つ
一つは
日本に生まれて
夢を描かない
追いかけないというのはもったいないと
いうことです
もちろんいろんな境遇にいる方が
いらっしゃるでしょうけれども
今日お話しした
シリアの内戦の被害者の人たちや
スーダンのダルフールの国内避難民の一つ
のことを考えると
僕らはずっと恵まれているはずです
ですから
夜そのことを考えるともうちょっと眠れ
なくなるような
これができたら自分の人生本望って言える
ぐらいの頃からの夢っていうのを持って
ください
二つ目は勝手に天井を作らないということ
22年前のどこにでもいる普通の大学生
だった当時の僕が
国境なき医師団
ハーバードって言っても
バカにされました
でも今から考えると可能性はあったんです
ですから確率論じゃなくて自分の可能性を
信じるようにしてください
そして最後に
個人としての成功よりもはるかに大事な
もののために自分の命を大きく使って
ください
ありがとうございました